I'm really happy for you yeah that
iconic moment just turned 10 let you
finish September 13 2009 Beyonce had one
of the best videos of all time Taylor
Swift and Kanye West gave us one of the
greatest views
pop culture history has ever known
[Music]
let's set the scene Taylor arrived in a
freaking Cinderella carriage it's her
second VMAs she's nominated for Best
Female Video against pink pink Perry
Lady Gaga Kelly Clarkson and of course
Beyonce which we'll come back to in
about 15 seconds but let's remember
Kanye arrived Wigan a bottle of Hennessy
with then girlfriend Amber Rose remember
that relationship and yeah he's wearing
sunglasses inside the Hennessy might
explain what went down that night maybe
but there's also Kanye's then friendship
with Z and J's it's unclear if they're
still friends
Kanye West are we friends but let's be
honest Taylor Swift put into written a
more perfect Taylor Swift setup and
Beyonce was just so mortified and a tiny
reminder Beyonce did end up winning the
biggest award of the night video of the
year which Taylor wasn't nominated for
but honey was so there's that but that's
the Taylor backstage she has this to say
to the EP cameras I was standing on
stage and I was really excited because I
had just won the award and then I was
really excited because Kanye West was on
the stage then I wasn't so excited
anymore suddenly everyone had something
to say about Taylor it's been
interesting definitely John Mayer Katy
Perry pink Lauren Conrad John Stamos
even Donald Trump called for a Kanye
boycott which is even weirder ten years
later so I've had a really really fun
night after that night's getting Kanye
it became a thing people said you all
are entertained and the reenactments got
real I'm really happy I let you finish
and
I want to thank bTW [ __ ] who's me Kanye
I'm gonna let you continue but the
moment also sparked a rollercoaster
relationship for Taylor and Kanye which
we are about to dive into you're welcome
these are things that make you break out
in a full-body sweat Taylor returned to
the VMAs in 2010 with this montage and
played a song she wrote about Kanye I
had an entire year to process
so you're not a grudge holder it's case
by case Kanye apologized then I
apologized to Taylor that shouldn't even
categorize with greatest living artist
that we have to date he even started
taking credit for her success 100
magazine covers in selling million first
week fast forward to 2015 of the Grammys
they were totally hanging out shaking
hands taking pictures BAM oh I should
also tell you this was the first time
Kanye hadn't been at the Grammys in six
years
I'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face Kanye he's music so Taylor the
next day yeah she wants to get in the
studio and we definitely gotta go in it
I think we've talked about it but we've
also talked about so many other things
and then back at the VMAs Taylor Kanye's
herself I'm really happy for you and
imma let you finish but Kanye West
that's like one of the greatest careers
of all time and we really thought
everything was gonna be okay I am
honored to present the 2015 Vanguard
Award to my friend Kanye West but I
think we all know that did not last
updated like Mia Taylor my still has sex
Wow I made that [ __ ] famous the Taylor
prove the lyric that she not did she
approve a different version out of the
lyric we may never really know I'm not
gonna stress about it
what we do know kim jiae's version of
the story played out on Keeping Up with
the Kardashians the camera crew filmed
him speaking to Taylor and got their
whole conversation I think she got
freaked out by the reaction and all of a
sudden she flipped
Taylor made the most epic no zap
statements in the history of Notes app
statements yeah that's a thing and a new
phrase is born excluded from this
narrative game called Taylor it's Nate
Taylor's shirt
am i right see aimed a few lyrics at
Kanye we blamed her for decline in radio
play really ever since the Taylor Swift
moment had never been the same
and there's still no real resolution
though Kim says I feel as we've all
moved on but have we no Taylor did
return to the VMAs in 2019 where she won
video of the year talk about full circle
several points were made she also won
the video for good award and it wasn't
lost on anyone but she did the opposite
of what Kanye did to her ten years prior
but anyways we are still waiting for Kim
Kanye and Taylor to officially put their
situation behind them and prove that
we're all capable of forgiveness
Redemption and number one radio hits
like I don't understand how you cannot
fangirl about that and with that I say
the anniversary Taylor and Kanye imma
let you finish whoa iconic Beyonce had
one of the best videos of all time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]